hi my name is steve jackson um thank you
for joining us
i'm the associate director of
applications development at thermal
fisher scientific
in the genetic sciences division in
today's talk i'm going to tell you a
little bit about how you can
analyze cells that you've taken out of
human subjects
and manipulate them in vitro this is
important because you want to make sure
the cells that you're working with are
the same as the cells that you think
you're dealing with
and mistakes are not made in terms of
identity of those cells
so um in general this is known as human
sample matching
and um this is a very important because
the research of human development and
diseases relies on the analysis of cells
that you take out of human subjects and
analyze them ex vivo you put them in
culture dishes
or on slides and you analyze them you
know outside of their normal environment
these sorts of of human samples can
include
pluripotent stem cells cell lines
chimeric receptor t
cells and and even slices that are ffpe
preserved on slides tumor
and normal matched for example it's
critical when you study these cells and
all your studies to know that the the
providence of the cells you know where
they have come from and you confirm that
these cells are in fact what you think
they should be
um it's also critical critical to
confirm that once these cells have been
manipulated outside of of
the uh of the subject you manipulated in
vitro
that the cells have the differential
characteristics that you want them to
and then the
genomic genomic integrity has been
maintained
all these are very important for making
sure that the cells are again
correct so there are various ways the
human sample
matching can be done it involves
confirming the identity of existing cell
lines and this is usually known as cell
and authentication
it's important for establishing the
provenance of new cell lines you might
establish in your own laboratory
you get a fingerprint of these cells so
that you know
that down the road those cells have
maintained their identity
it's a way for tracking human tumor
xenographs and mouse models
um when you're doing induced pluripotent
stem cell research it's a way
for matching the undifferentiated cells
to differentiate cells that you have
manipulated in in culture conditions
it's in car t research it's matching the
manipulated cells to the original donor
cells
and in biobanking it's important for
sample tracking and matching as i
mentioned you know tumor
to normal or different tissue samples
from the same
donor so all of these are very important
for making sure that the human samples
are indeed what you think they are
and one big example of why this is
important is because
as you know there have been cell line
models that have been used for human
disease research for
for over 50 years now and over the
course of these
these um studies there have been 500
reported misidentified cell lines um
that that have happened you know that
the cells that have been
experimented on are not what the the
investigator thought they were
for example there have been over 700
publications of this mda
mb 435 cell line this was originally
described as a breast cancer cell line
but it was later determined to be a
melanoma
um and so over-centered public patients
um have
have modeled uh breast cancer disease
when factors of melanoma so there's
that's a big problem
and because of this nih um and and
um certain journals are now requiring
that uh when you uh submit a grant
application or when you submit a
a publication that you have um
of some kind of evidence or plan for for
uh for authenticating the cells
that you're using in your studies and
they want to make sure that that you
have a plan for making sure your cells
don't become contaminated
and that you're using the right cell
lines throughout the course of your of
your work
for ex fever research again you must be
prepared to make sure your donor and
recipient of the manipulative sales
match
and for biobanking it's very important
to make sure the samples
are are from the same individual when
you think they are
so one of the ways that this human
central matching is done is by making a
dna profile
um this is a forensic method that
differentiates two or more individuals
based on their genotype at specific and
highly variable loci
you probably have seen this do in
television programs where you do a ding
and dna fingerprint
and it provides a very specific way to
match a sample to a human
donor or subject the more low side
they're used for this the greater the
power of discrimination
and so one of the most common ways to do
this is shown here there are
all these different uh highly variable
short-tend and repeat sequences i'll
have more to see about them second
that are scattered throughout the genome
and most of the forensic identification
kits make use of these different regions
uh
between eight and and twenty four of
them to come up with a molecular
fingerprint that is unique for
individual
these uh dna fingerprints are consists
of short tandem repeat sequences
these strs are microsatellite regions
between two and five
repeat lengths they are simply repeated
at at random or pseudorandom
frequencies um uh in uh individuals
and they're highly polymorphic because
they can vary quite a bit between
individuals they don't have any
necessarily
a functional role they simply are are
length markers that
are unique for an individual the allele
length is determined by the number of
repeat units that are present and so for
example this individual has
one uh one homolog has
seven repeats on them and the other
homolog has eight repeats so two
versions because they're
uh they're deployed and seven eight
repeats um and
and at this locus then there's a there's
you know um
a fingerprint of seven and eight that
that uh that can be
uh analyzed um these can then uh above
for each one of the different loci that
you're analyzing is you can set up a
highly multiplex pcr reaction
and this is a standard method that's
used in forensic analysis
and the way this works is that when you
when you um when you
generate this this pcr product you
compare it to an allelic ladder
um this is an example of a photograph of
a of the electroferogram that comes off
of the allelic ladder here
showing all the different uh
possibilities of framing lengths
therefore the different low side that
are present
so so when you then look at a sample
that that you want to to verify um you
do the pcr and
and um and run the uh the the ce
experiment again the left
electrophorogram is shown here on the
right
and then you simply match up the peaks
that are shown on the right with the
allelic ladder that
that is run at the same time and then
that will give you then
the different alleles that are present
in the sample for all the different loci
that are present in electrophoreogram
this is done automatically for you by
the software by the way it's not
something you have to do but the
software will then be able to call out
these these alleles and provide for you
the fingerprint
uh to elect your fingerprint of the of
the sample that you're analyzing
and so when this is done with the um the
thermo fissure kits
which were collectively known as the uh
identifier or global filer kits
we analyze up to 16 different loci and
five different dies for the identifier
kits
and what's shown here are the different
alleles that
are following the identifier kit itself
um
we have um 16 different loci
that they're identified and as a result
of that there's a six point one eight
times
minus 29th chance of having um a
mismatch or having the same individual
have the same allelic profile because of
all the variability that's present in
these different loci um the global filer
kit is a little bit more advanced
it has six different dyes and includes
24 different loci that can use be used
for
for extra discrimination as you can see
here you get a 7.7
times 10 to the minus 28th chance of
having two individuals with the same
global filer profile as a result of that
now there are some databases like atcc
and there's dsm z in in europe that that
provides for cell lines
ways to to match some of the output of
these different allelic
fingerprints that you get to known
allelic fingerprints for known cell
lines
and you can then verify the identity of
these cell lines based on the match-up
of the alleles that that
that are what you get versus what has
been deposited
atcc or dsmz or rican panels
for example you can do a fingerprint of
hela cells you're going in culture
and match that fingerprint with what
atcc says should be a
a heal of fingerprint to make sure the
hela cells you have
are in fact hela cells
this as i mentioned this makes it very
easy then to cross
check your cell lines and make sure that
that the cells that are in your culture
dish
match up with what these organizations
say have been deposited into their
databases
so thermo fisher scientific has as i
mentioned a couple of different ways for
analyzing
these these forensic samples they're
based off of the the
identifier direct and identify their
plus kits i'll just show you an example
using the identifier direct kit because
i think this is one of the easier ways
to go about doing this
the identifier direct kit doesn't
require nucleic acid purification you
can simply spot
the the cells in in culture
um onto these nucleic cards you take a
spot then of the nucleic carbs and
amplify it up
analyzed by by a capillary
electrophoresis and analyze using our
gene mapper software
to show how this works i've i i
collected a bunch of different cell
lines
and we suspended them in pbs spotted
them onto
the nucleic cards as you can see on the
right hand side here
took a little bit uh a 1.2 millimeter
punch out of each one of the center of
the dried
dried cards here and then went through
the identifier direct
workflow and what i was able to do is
is to match up using the the different
cell lines that that have been
deposited in the atcc match up the
allelic frequencies that that
i would expect based on what the atcc
found and you can see that that using
about five times ten to the fifth cells
i get 100
match um on the different instruments
that we sell here
going down to five times ten to the
fourth and five times five times ten to
the third cells
per per microliter per ml um in
in those dilutions um i got a slight
reduction the frequency at which the
correct calls are made but i can still
pick up the
the right alleles um um
in those experiments and so we recommend
that you spot at least five to ten of
the fifth cells per mill on the
copan nucleic card um in your in your
analyses
now these these coping nucleic cards are
very handy because you can keep these
these cells in the dried state um
for uh for years um it doesn't require
freezer space
the nucleic acids are stable on the
copan card for years and so you can
always go back to these cards then
take another punch and analyze them as
necessary
um this is another experiment where we
mixed uh
known amounts of m4a for gfp cells and
hela cells here
and this was a way to kind of see if we
could detect
what fraction of the cells we could
detect as being
contaminating in an experiment here and
in this mixtures then which you can see
by the circled red dots
is that our circle uh circle red uh um
ellipses is that instead of having a
normal diploid
one or two allelic uh representations in
each one of these different loci
when there's a mixture present you
sometimes see three different cells
indicated by these circles here
and so then going into the um the uh
different dilutions of the gila cells i
simply mix them into known uh
percentages spotted onto the copa
nucleic cards and was able to detect
hela cells down to at least 10 percent
of a mixture in in that population um i
could see at least half of the of the
heli-specific alleles that were
that were present in that in that in
that mixture i'm showing that the
the nucleic cards are very nice for even
even analyzing mixtures of cells
we identify their plus cells i i uh
purify genomic dna from the same
mixtures and i was able to detect
heliospheric loci
down to about one percent of of a
mixture so if one percent of the
contaminating cells are hela cells
i was still able to detect about one in
five of the heliospecific loci present
there
um and so this is a very nice way to to
to determine whether or not you have
mixture of cells or a mixture of samples
present
because the the the specific
fingerprint you generate um can pick up
contaminating low side down to very low
concentrations
um again the the munich alleles can be
detected down to around 10 to 50 percent
of the population
um in in copan cards down to about one
to two percent
um um when you're just looking at at
um single uh allelic differences
in a mixed population
as i mentioned before the global filer
is another one that provides a higher
level of discrimination because it has
24 different loci that can be analyzed
here we do similar mixing experiments
with the global filer cells
and we were able to detect down about
4.6 percent of the mixture
um detecting all the different alleles
from
from the gila cell mixture there
um so as i mentioned at the start at the
start of the talk
matching induced pluripotent cells with
car t cells is very important um
it's it's it's critical to be able to
know that the
the cells that you have treated outside
of the individual
um are are matched to the donors um and
so
in this case here uh we we took some car
t cells
um from uh from some donors
they were manipulated um
x vivo and then uh just to show that
that the executable manipulation did not
change the characteristic of the
of the car t cells we matched the
allelic profile
using identifier kit of these different
donors and showed that the car t cells
uh match up the t cells that we got from
the donors in the first place
for the new pluripotent stem cells we
did a similar sort of experiment where
um we we got a a series of 24 different
um
donor and starting
cells and iondo splurp stem cells
ran a profile on them and matched up
the the donor to the ipscs in this case
when i did these experiments they were
blinded to me
and so i i didn't know the identity of
of the
of the samples but by using the the
identifier kit i was able to correctly
match up the the donor to the ipscs
um 100 of the time and completely
accurately
so um this is described an application
note that you should be able to get um
in collaboration
this i should say this works on a
collaboration with uh with dr wang at
central university
and the the work describing this is in
an application note
you can download from our website
and so um one other um
[Music]
important avenue of the the quality
control is making sure that when you're
uh
making these induced pluripotent stem
cells that you um
either have complete pluripotency um
or that you you um
you have to have put the cells down the
correct induced
path here but when you do these these um
these manipulations of of cells
culturing them um you can often get
aberrations um and traditionally you
know these chromosomal aberrations
um after long passage in particular are
detected by using uh
g banding but this is a highly um um
specialized and difficult uh process to
uh to
um to do one of the better ways to make
sure that you haven't induced a a a
chromosomal anomaly by passage in
culture is to do a molecular profile
using the the karyostat microarray
um this is is um um
a way to to just take snapshots across
the whole genome and make sure that
you're not getting
chromosomal anomalies you know
chromosomal losses or duplications
um by by making use of of snips
um and probes across the entire uh
genome
to see if if there have been induced
duplications deletions um
or other sorts of anomalies the
kerryostat is a low resolution
resolution way to do this
and we also have something called the
karyosat hd
and in this case using the carious stat
hd uh and these induced uh uh
pluripotent stem cells are able to show
that the the carry set hd
did pick up some smaller aberrations at
multiple loci
that were not present in the parental
line um
but but because of the high resolution
of the carryout hd we're able to find
them
and and at least have an idea about
where we had duplications or loss of
chromosomal integrity
um in these loci so these these
molecular karyotypes can reveal novel
variations at a resolution that's better
than g banding
another thing you might want to do is to
look for the oncogenic potential of
these uh manipulated cells
um you know by passaging them in in
culture you can introduce and introduce
novel mutations and
uh you will particularly um
want to check to make sure whether or
not you have introduced a hot spot
mutation or mutations in hot spot genes
they're known to be oncogenic
one of the ways this is done in a
publication that we that we showed
that we that we came up with was by
making use of the ion torrent oncoming
comprehensive assay
um this is a way to to use the ion
torrent platform to quickly check
whether or not there are hotspot
mutations in
uh in a cell line it checks for
gene fusions indels and hot spots for uh
for 161 unique
uh tumor driver mutations or tumor
driver genes
and so in these ipscs we did an ion
torrent hotspot
uh analysis here just as a subject of
subset
of them looking at the tp i'm sorry p53
mutations
we didn't see um in that we introduced
anything in the p53 locus
similarly we didn't see anything in the
wrasse or or raf or any other
loci they're known to to be hot spots
for oncogenic mutations
so a quick way of analyzing the genome
to see
to make sure that you have not
introduced a hot spot
oncogenic mutation in your manipulated
cells
and then finally the pluripotency of
induced pluripotent stem cells um that
that you have maple and vitro can be um
confirmed by using the taqman hpsc
scorecard
this is a qpcr assay that makes use of
well-known markers for
for either undifferentiated cells or for
cells they're in an endodermic mesoderm
or
ectodermic lineage when we look at
clones of these ipscs
we see a a uh
presence uh um of a high presence of the
um of all different lineages or um
in the uh in in undifferentiated cells
but once we move down the differentiated
pathway the the
um
eb cells um show that their um
uh absence of self-renewal and and
lineage markers were
were upregulated in in
as a result of actually going down the
the um
the differentiated uh treatments um this
is also shown here on the graphs on on
the
on right hand side here where the self
renewal
uh gene expressions are low levels but
as a result of the differentiation you
get some ectodermal mesodermal
endodermal
pathways enriched
so the index plot shows that the the the
self-regulation decreases and the
lineage markers increase in expression
once you start
the differentiation process
so when you are are um quality
controlling the
um ex vivo cells and we uh we recommend
there are several different things that
you should be doing
and there's some best practices that we
can recommend um
to guarantee the cells are are what you
think they should be
so um what i didn't talk about but one
thing is when you're working with
induced blurred protein stem cells we
recommend the cells
get get grown in a xenographic sorry a
gene
a xenogenic free medium that supports
the isolation expansion and
reprogramming of donor
fibroblast cells this is something that
our gibko line
has has provided and is easy to easy to
find
when you're looking at at any of the
parental and derived cell lines uh we
we recommend using the um identifier or
global filer analysis kit to make sure
that the
str uh um str care um
fingerprints match up with each other um
in
in related cells we recommend confirming
genomic identity i didn't
we recommend that the genomic integrity
was not compromised
um in a manipulation by making use of
the karyostat or curious
hd whole genome arrays this
again makes sure that you haven't
introduced novel deletions duplications
loss of chromosomes of either a small
portion or the whole chromosome itself
you can confirm the tri-lineage
differentiation differentiation
potential
um uh by using the taqman human uh
psc scorecard assay um and this allows
you to see
the expression levels of self-renewal
and
lineage path expression markers
and then finally we recommend that that
when you are looking at
uh car t cells or ipscs that you look
for hotspot
tumor causing mutations that have been
introduced by pathogenic cell
using the oncoming comprehensive cancer
assay it's a very simple assay
that will allow you to quickly identify
whether or not
new mutations in oncogenic hot spots
have been
introduced as a result of your passage
so finally i want to thank david yoder
for for a lot of his basic work on the
cell
cell line authentication paths that we
talked about
the group in in the bid
that that worked on the ipscs and the
car t
uh data uh carl dargates chad macarthur
mark langan
umalakshmi pathy and comedy varma under
whose direction a lot of this work was
done
thank you very much for listening